hello YouTube I'm Rick abrianna social
enterprise the United States called
Rubicon programs you hate social
entrepreneurship at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business here at
Davos trying to figure out whether the
environment is going to lose out to the
economy in two thousand and I in the
midst of this whole global crisis just
took the opposition without door where
are these parts making the very
important profound comment that the
economy in the environment and it's
strictly bound together and that wise
and smart that it's not a choice that
mr. date that the two are together I'm
certainly hopeful myself or one of the
things that we do at our social
enterprise make big new businesses that
are going to have huge impacts of the
United States and we're doing one and
the waste management arena in the
recycling of mattresses we think that
significant investments may impact flows
so that rather than landfills getting
filled up with such things as mattresses
and carpets actually businesses can get
created where homeless men and women
people moving out of prisons and other
people who are marching and the economy
can affect get jobs created through
environmental innovations and through
environmental investments of 2009 so I'm
hopeful that the it's not a choice that
it's being a thank you very much